[Music]
all right it's finally here it arrived
i'm just gonna try to get this in proper
focus right here see it's it says for
100k subscribers it has my name it's
very legit it's very silvery very shiny
and this this part in the middle is like
a mirror you see this
amazing it is super cool i'm very very
excited this arrived i would not ever
have believed when i started that that
this would at some point be in the mail
it's incredible that a hundred thousand
of you are interested in very lengthy
and long-winded explanations about ml
research or or news in this space or
anything like this so giant thank you to
every single one of you that is
subscribed if you're not subscribed what
are you doing uh the button is right
there somewhere um no but really giant
thanks to the people who watch who come
back to watch content all the people who
leave a comment i do still read try to
read like every single comment i i don't
always respond but i do take your
suggestions very seriously and very big
thanks to the discord community
especially to the moderators there they
they have a huge job there are spam bots
and and whatnot so giant thanks to the
moderators they also organize paper
discussion every saturday we have paper
discussions and these are like some of
the most valuable times because i end up
learning so much myself and it really
helps me sometimes for new videos that i
put out where i directly take well you
know people's opinions from there and
try to integrate it into the video so
you know giant thanks to all of that
community anyone who's ever helped me
out all the authors who've come on this
it's it's been extremely rewarding and i
hope i can i can keep up the content i
hope i can continue to deliver good
content it's it's not so easy on youtube
because you have to change in order to
to stay interesting and relevant you
have to go with the times but still you
have to keep the essence of what makes
channel great and this is a challenge
and i'm relying also on you a little bit
to tell me what's good what's bad what
works i'm also going to try some new
stuff i hope you've enjoyed so far the
more inclusion of the original authors
of papers i think that's super valuable
the ml news it looks like it's more
click-baity but um and it's less work
but it's actually also i've i really
enjoy making the ml news but also it is
more more time goes in there scheduling
the authors i'm by nature i'm not an
organized person so scheduling people
and keeping up and sending them stuff
before that that is a true challenge to
me and i hope i can master that in also
that from here on so enough of a rant
thank you again so much to anyone who's
helped me to all the patreons all the
supporters in any form it truly helps it
means a lot to me i hope i can continue
making good content and i hope we can go
forward together with that being said
you might have noticed something else
which
so people over the years have asked me
again and again for merch this honestly
it's more for myself because i i just
think it's fun to walk around with the
channel logo on like a hoodie or
something but if you want to support the
channel and want something a little bit
in return merch could be an option for
you if you enjoy these things all right
so i'm gonna show you some of the merch
right here and we should talk about
prices i just came to this website it's
called teespring i think now it's called
spring and i just left all the the
default prices at their setting now the
idea is obviously that isn't just a
markup for you know a regular clothes
retailer it is a bit more because the
idea is that you'd support the creator
however that makes the merch kind of
pricey so you know for people who can't
afford this i've decided that for
five days after this video goes up all
the markup will be set to zero like i
will not make a single dollar off of
this merch if you buy it five days after
this video goes up now if you have
already bought merch like this i've
activated the merch shelf a while ago
and you would like to make use of that
you know contact me we can for sure work
something out if you do want to support
the channel uh you can become a patreon
i have several ways of supporting me all
the links are in the description or you
just wait for a week and you you get the
merch then but i just thought you know
if you
wanna run around advertising my channel
then and you you don't have much money
or you like three t-shirts instead of
one or instead of two you know knock
yourselves out
uh yeah just five days and we'll do
things like this in the future again
this won't be the only time where the
merch is uh reduced and there will be
other merch coming i'm i'm looking for
like sunglasses merch which is hard to
find i can tell you and i'm also working
together with a bit more let's say
professional designers to get more just
just kind of more extra extravagant
merch out there again five days markup
zero after that i'll set it back to the
default values look at this the ice is
so thin
but still the birds they just
insane
so i'm wearing one right now i had to
you had a have a few iterations people
who followed me on stream saw the first
iterations this is kind of the second
iteration i wanted to make sure
everything is placed nicely before i
shout it out so it has the logo in small
right here this is a hoodie it is a a
small european and extra small u.s i
don't know why they differ these sizes
i'm not too
tall of a person and it fits kind of
kind of snuggly i'm like
175. for you americans that's like uh a
num some number of feet the same design
also exists in black as you can see now
this was the first iteration so the logo
is too far out here so in the newer
iteration the logo will be a little bit
more inside it's almost like under the
arm right here but i do quite like the
the white logo on the black background
makes it pop a little bit more there is
one person one of you has actually
bought a first iteration hoodie after
seeing the store on stream if you would
like that replaced with a newer
iteration hoodie or or just if you would
like one i'm very happy to send you an
additional one please contact me because
i i feel kind of bad because yeah it is
it is a bit out of place but rest
assured if you get the black hoodie now
the logo will be in the correct place
and it looks popping by the way there's
nothing on on the back of any of these
i've opted for kind of smaller logos
so that it doesn't look like traditional
merch however as you can see we also
have the large logo available again this
is an s i am a small person but i have a
bunch of shoulders this fits kind of
snuggly here
it is it is okay if you're taller than
me i definitely suggest like an m we
also have t-shirts with the smaller logo
design if that's your favorite these are
also available in dark
and we also have this design right here
now this is the channel model which you
might have never actually seen directly
it is not something that i've shouted
out in particular but i think the design
looks cool and there is a little story
behind it when we were at the end of
high school we used to play a lot of
online poker which was sort of at its
peak back then and we used to play
online and also circulate in poker
forums where people discussed strategy
and things like this we always took sort
of a statistical approach because
essentially you're playing towards an
expected value and you're trying to be
as mentally robust as possible against
the variance that inevitably comes so at
one point there was this one player who
just let off like steam in one of these
forum posts essentially saying that the
world is against them they always get
the bad cards and if they have good
cards the opponent always gets lucky and
it's just every time it's happening just
kind of the entire universe is
conspiring against them that's why they
lose right and it's unfair and they were
just really really really ticked off and
one of the people who responded was this
very high ranked players one of the
highest ranked players at the time he
just responded with this one line skill
greater than destiny and i just thought
that was really really cool i'm not a
deep philosophical person or anything
like this it resonated with me since
then i've took it up as a little bit of
a motto a little bit of a mantra to live
by and the meaning of it is obviously
subjective but to me i've interpreted as
something like it doesn't matter how
much the world is stacked against you
how much your destiny has chosen a path
for you that is not good doesn't matter
if the system is rigged against you you
can overcome it by working hard by
putting in all your effort in fact it
doesn't matter how the world is you
can't change that you can change
yourself and you can try to do the best
you can yeah if you're smart work hard
and obviously a little bit of luck is
always of essence but independent of how
the world is structured you should do
your best and that's just something that
i think is nice to have somewhere around
every time you look at it it kind of
reminds you that oh wait i'm just gonna
try to do my best today and not get mad
at how unfair the world or the system is
to you
and the absolute cool thing is if you
get the zip up hoodie you can like
double represent look at that yeah we
also have this beauty right here which
is actually it's a crop top you can't
even see it so again the logo here will
be placed in the current iteration more
inside more on top a little bit smaller
but i think looks pretty cool so if
you're interested check out the store
it's available at
store.whyculture.com there's a link in
the description there's also a tab
directly next to this video we also have
other stuff other than just clothes for
example uh there is the beaker right
here now the logo again is a bit tall
here a bit large so we're gonna make
this a little bit smaller but in essence
this is a cool beaker it holds half a
liter that's like some gallon for
americans it really keeps stuff warm on
the inside the lid is a a it kind of
pops off like this and it has an it has
a seal on the outside uh so it's not
screw on
but press on there's also other stuff
such as cups and uh these right here
pillows so i have these two in different
sizes so they go together they go
together nicely on it on a couch but i
i don't i don't know who wants these but
i find them i find them hilarious
and with that being said thank you so
much for being here for continue to
watch continue to enjoy and uh most of
all you know i really appreciate all the
people who helped me who gave me
feedback i still try to read every
single comment what you people post is
really valuable and shapes the future of
the channel and i hope we can continue
doing that definitely with that being
said i wish you an absolute pleasant
rest of the day and i'll see you
bye
have i told you that i quite like hoods
like i don't know what it is but
something about hoods it just it's
snuggly and if you have very short hair
the hook kind of turns with your with
your head
and i just love that feeling
you